hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so i'm back guys to
make a big update on amc a lot of things
happened this week bulls are taking back
control so let's see exactly what
happened and let's try to see what can
happen next let's get into it
[Music]
oh right guys so anc daily time frame
where can i start so in my last video
guys it was last week so it was bam bam
bam we were again around 14.5 guys so
what happened we tested this level
for the fourth time so it was starting
to get weak but bulls managed to push
the price action higher it all happened
in
three days i would say
so it started with the eighth of feb
where we went to the
17.4 level right so it was here guys
so this was a resistance so basically
where is the resistance area here in
this downtrend what we are doing here
guys we are looking for a bullish signal
so to find the bullish signal we first
need to find the level where you have
the resistance where bears are all
gathered and waiting you know to sell
and this level here was created by this
trend line right the yellow trend line
you can see guys here
so i'm monitoring this trend line for
quite some time and
you can use the 20-day moving average as
well which is often gonna give you the
same level as the resistance trend line
so here this level was here around
17.4 guys and like i said everything has
been done in three days
so we had some good news we had some uh
lee's agreement with unibike rademko
there is a debt restructuring that is
happening as well uh i think that amc
wanted to issue 500 million us dollars
of bone so it's a bond offering to
restructure the debt and actually
they're going to do twice the size which
is good news because it's going to help
them to have a lower interest on the
futures payment all right so this is
good news guys uh and we have the
earnings coming in march so
i think that
this earnings will be good guys and we
are in to buy the rumor i hope not sell
the news mode but it seems like
investors
want to buy amc
at the moment so what is the situation
guys we had this breakup so let's
analyze
so the breakout happened on the 9th of
feb guys
once again because of all this you know
news that was coming the global market
was looking good at that time i'm gonna
do a global market video in two days
guys where i'm gonna show you that the
bull trap
uh has been actually set
by bears and that i don't know what will
happen but it's not looking good on the
global market
but for now guys let's go back to emc so
we had this breakout all right above
the 17.4
level so let's analyze first
once you have a breakout usually boos
are taking back control but the breakout
needs to be good quality breakout what i
call a good and reliable breakout so to
know if it's a good and reliable
breakout we need to check the volume the
volatility and the momentum guys so
let's start with the volume the volume
was low just before the breakout which
is good and then we have this volume
increase all the way up during the
breakout okay so that's looking great as
you can see we had three bullish days
with the volume growing each time and
during the breakout the volume was
very high so this is good but what is
not good guys is that we have this red
day that is higher than everything else
that came after so that's not good for
breakouts to be really good quality we
would like to see a volume that was
greater than all the red days before or
i mean at least greater than the red
days that happened not long ago like
this one so the volume analysis is not
perfect but it's still good enough for
this breakout to be followed by more
buyers then volume is done volatility
guys so we need to check if the price
action was contained in a tight range in
a nice consolidation before the breakout
and if basically there is there was you
know this period of balance between
bulls and bears just before this
breakout if it was the case then it
means that the breakout once again will
probably be followed by more buyers so
to know that you just check if there is
a consolidation here the consideration
is not perfect guys we have a
consideration that happened okay here
true
but what i like to see the consideration
really close to the trend line and this
consideration is not perfect so we need
to use another tool to assess if the
volatility was low enough during this
breakout and we have the bollinger bands
guys
so let's use that and i'm on a daily
timeframe because i'm checking a
correction that is lasting for three
months so the daily time frame is
adapted once again guys what i'm doing
here is actually what i'm um explaining
in my course which is about breakouts so
i'm here showing you guys a little bit
what it is about and it is about
actually using the momentum the volume
the volatility to understand what is the
market sentiment and to use breakouts as
an entry signal as a buying signal
whenever you have a correction that
seems to be over right but there are
many things to do so that's why i'm
showing you here a little bit what it is
about and in my course guys i'm of
course giving you all the different
techniques that you need to know for
example to enter then to exit once
you're in the trade so i basically try
to make everything as clear as possible
guys uh to show how i like to take my
trades and what is to me very efficient
for those who want to know more just
click on the link in the description of
this video for now it's still the elliot
wave landing page i'm working on uh the
new landing page but just subscribe to
that so at least i have your email and
you will be sent the information
whenever the course will be available
and of course you're gonna get the
discount so
let's go back to what i was saying here
guys so the bollinger bands are not
extremely tight let's be honest but they
were getting tighter all right so i'm
here i'm assessing if the market posed
for long enough for bears to really you
know
be out of this trade all right whenever
you have a pose that is very long okay
like i don't know for example here you
see the market pose for quite some time
then it means that bears are not
attacking amc anymore and so bulls can
take back control using a catalyzer such
as some news and a breakout okay
here the consolidation is not perfect
right and i can say that visually and i
can say that using bollinger bands
because they were tight but not as tight
as they could be all right
so i would say the volatility indicator
is telling me that
this breakout is good but not incredible
then
i'm gonna use the momentum guys i'm
gonna get rid of the bollinger bands
volume has been done volatility has been
done and momentum guys the momentum is
telling me
here as you can see the macd is going
higher between december and january
while the market is going lower you guys
know that this is a bullish regular
divergence all right so whenever you
have a bullish regular divergence it
means that bears are tired they are out
of steam it doesn't mean that the move
down is going to stop it just gives you
one information about the fact
that
the move down is slowing all right and
then if you have a breakout like we do
right now guys this is a breakout once
again
okay and if you have a breakout
associated with this bullish regular
divergence then you are in a very
favorable environment to
take long positions all right so here we
are guys so to conclude this breakout is
tradable it's a good breakout but it's
not a perfect breakout so
as it is not a perfect breakout what
could happen in this situation is at
least a retest of the breakout area
or a fakeout okay so i it's impossible
to say what is the probability of a fake
out i would give it a 30 chance from
here roughly using my experience and i
would use fibs in this situation to know
where the three tests might potentially
go and usually
in this situation so once again this
breakout happened after a very sharp
move down we usually see some re-tests
that uh come quite deep
so the 61.8 fib retracement is around 16
this is the breakout level as well i
have the 20-day moving average around 17
and i have
the 38.2 percent of fib around 18 which
is a very nice support as well so in
this situation i would say that what
could happen this week because this is
why you guys are watching this video and
as you know i usually give my view so my
view is
that we're probably going to retest the
18 level okay and
there is
i think a high probability we go
slightly lower so maybe to the 17 worst
case 16 level okay so my view is that
maybe monday tuesday wednesday i don't
know early week we see maybe some dip
and that after that
we would go higher this is in the
situation this breakout is holding so
let's see if it does once again i give
it a 70 chance it does so let's see what
will happen and if it does this is the
scenario that could happen and after
that guys
it means that this
entire move is complete right
this move here
okay
so we would at least go to the 38.2 of
this move down all right so the
38.2 of this correction would be 25 but
i don't have anything around 25 so i'm
checking what is the the closest
resistance to this 25 and it's here 26.5
so my take is that we dip a little bit
we come back again in the range 1821 as
you know guys and i've been sharing that
information all the week in my discord
21 is a resistance level i personally
sold some calls at this level as i
bought those calls before so it's like
selling some covert calls and i'm gonna
buy back this position a little bit
lower and i think we might go back in
the 1821 range for some time and then
break it on the upside and go test the
26.5 level so when i don't know guys but
you know just visually maybe around
early march mid-march you know maybe
after earnings you know
this is a possible scenario and after
that we would probably need to correct a
little bit and look at the big picture
guys the big picture is here so once
again i can't be sure this breakout will
hold
it looks like it it will hold okay to me
even if it's not perfect and if it does
the big picture guys is this breakout
right
and this is the level you really want to
see broken and ideally we would like to
see it broken perfectly so we'd like to
see a consolidation here
all right on low volume then a breakout
a retest and then we would go higher so
this could happen around april may okay
it will be related a lot to first the
earnings that we're gonna have here the
kobe crisis are people really gonna be
able to go back to cinema uh it's also
gonna be related to the fed rates policy
are they going to be more hawkish or
dovish that the market thinks right now
i don't know
so if the global market
finally stops dropping you know maybe
around march april
this could be a good uh environment for
amc to really do its uh nice move up
that we are waiting for so long so
that's it for the technical analysis
guys so this is my view i think we're
gonna have kind of you know some ups and
downs this week
with a support around 16 uh the lowest
level and i don't think we're going to
break above 21 this week guys i think we
need one more week then break out above
21 go to 27 consolidate and hopefully
break out above this blue trend line
that is the long term uh correction we
are trying to uh stop okay now let's
have a look guys at the information
about the option market the synthetic
short guys the regular shot the dtc okay
let's check all of that so last week i
did the video i told you guys that the
synthetic short on amc was zero percent
uh so it's like the total
short so basically you have some long
position that is coming from the put
options all right so right now we have
three percent of synthetic long okay
and the synthetic shot has grown because
as you can see them
we're at four percent but if i subtract
the synthetics long which i should do to
get the entire position we are at
1.3 percent right now so we are positive
again because the synthetic short is
growing guys on the upside okay because
of all this massive coal options that we
have here so we are back in positive
territory and just to show you an
example if amc goes to i don't know
28
okay the total synthetic shot would uh
go to four percent okay guys so we're
gonna have synthetic short again on the
upside what else i wanted to show you so
right now the synthetic shot is 1.3 but
the maximum synthetic shot has grown
guys it was 12 it is 14.7 so we are
starting to go
back to some levels we've seen a few
months ago
all right let me show you that bam i'm
sure as you guys know keeping all the
information so on amc right now so last
week we had so you see the synthetic
shot was 0.1 so slightly positive but
not that much
right now it's 1.3 but the maximum
synthetic shot
has grown from 12.7
this column guys to 14.7 so it means
that a lot of call options have been
bought okay guys first thing and you can
see that before in you know november
for example it was around 20 guys so we
have lost a lot because of gen 22 expiry
but we can see already guys in one week
it took two percent guys so this is good
news to me once again i'm not saying to
go and buy this out of the money cool
options where the volatility is quite
expensive so you know they can generate
a lot of profits if there is a squeeze
but if there is no squeeze it's like um
you know a very good trade for market
makers so maybe it's not good to go
there
i don't know but what i know is that
this is the information i want to see to
know that the movement on amc is still
on and now as you guys can see it has
grown by two percent in one week
what else do we have this was fifth
fifth of feb as you can see we have the
dtc where is the dtc bam so same
no big difference in the dtc we went
from 2.1 to two okay so we're still far
from the three 3.5 we had in november
when we almost squeezed guys okay so
this is the information this is rather
good news to me i still don't have the
new regular short interest as of 28th of
jan the data is not available yet it's
gonna be next next week probably so for
now the total shot is 20 guys alright so
it's still
very substantial okay there is still a
lot of shot on this market the 145
strike has grown from 5.5 i think to
almost six
so once again
it's maybe not good to go and buy it but
some people do it and it's gonna create
troubles for option market makers if we
start to squeeze so this is to me good
to see that
and to conclude we can check the max
payne for option expiry on the 18th of
february guys and as you can see so this
is the payoff of all the options that
expire on that day and you can see that
the lowest
p l is here around 20. so this is the
max pain the maximum pain and it it
means that market makers
are going to try to push it towards this
direction all right so it's not always
happening like that but it's a good
indication because
you know this is what is better for them
so usually they will try to push it
there by selling and buying on the
market of course so it's 20 20 21 so
that makes sense for next week
i think that we would finish in the
range between 18 and 21. this is in line
with my analysis so let's see
let's see guys uh what else can i tell
you it's pretty much that guys it's
pretty much that we can check where is
the biggest option but we know it's
going to be around the 20 strike on the
feb 18s bam
yeah you see the 20 strike is huge guys
so once again when we're going to go
through it we're going to make big moves
and ultimately
if the max payne is respected we're
gonna get back to this level but if we
go through it it's gonna be big moves so
a lot of ups and downs around the 20
level
is a scenario that makes sense for the
coming week so that's it for me guys i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're going
to be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore i
see you guys